there's a whole bunch of people they're
wanting to hold and not move because
they don't see three days five days you
know two years out whatever and what i'm
saying is it's it's kind of like the
lights of a of a car
if i go to the parking lot at night turn
on the lights and say oh my gosh i can't
go where i don't see my house right well
no no no get the car start moving in the
direction you're supposed to move it and
guess what you only get about 300 feet
of light right you don't get you don't
get seven miles you don't get to see
your house you've got to utilize the
light you've got so that you can get to
where you want to go and so many people
they're uncomfortable with that with
that light yeah because it's there's
well it's not long enough and what's
around the corner and and the whole
issue is you don't you know what you
don't know what's around the corner
until you go around the corner oh gosh
that's so good and so you just
so you have to be very comfortable which
i am you have to be very comfortable
with traveling not having all the
answers so true but can i tell you
something the only way you get all the
answers is to go all the way through
absolutely